So, here's how far we've gotten. We have
our first polynomial factor, x+5, treated as
a block, and it is multiplying each of the
terms inside the second set of
parentheses. The next step is to apply the
distributive property, once again. You
know that we would rearrange each of these
terms so that the factor x+5 comes after
the factors that only have one term inside
them. And then once we got here we would
use the distributive property again, to
simplify for each of these terms. So let's
take a second and compare what we're doing
in this step of the problem to what we did
in the very first step. In both cases,
we're using the distributive property. We
used it the first time, so that we could
set ourselves up to do it again. Notice
though, which numbers and variables are
written here. We have an x and a -2 and
then we have an x and a +5. And those are
just the same terms that are in the two
polynomials up here. The things that we're
multiplying together are x and x, x and x,
x and 5, x and 5, -2 and x, -2 and x, and
5 and -2. What we've done here, using the
distributive property, is just make sure
that every term in the first polynomial is
multiplied by every term in the second
polynomial. Here we've reach another point
where we can use a sort of shortcut, so we
don't have to do quite as many steps in
the problem.